hey cutie-pie I am a last and I'm from
from would stupid arms and citrine come
on
hi how's it going brahs
finally being faced how's it going bros
my name is beatta path I asked you bros
on Facebook to send me a message it
could be whatever you want and I thought
we're gonna review them together on this
video let's go I'm a little nervous
oh Jesus Christ okay
don't hi how are you hi I'm a person I'm
a subscriber like this yeah
micro guy yeah we love it do you love it
yeah just keep making cool videos yeah
yeah thank you
hahahaha ah this is fun beautify your
more amazing your get a bed you what you
doing big lot thank you very much
appreciate
set a dowel hahaha it is a dowel okay oh
right
[ __ ] you [ __ ] Jesus career out I wasn't
scared what a shoe Kula bucket yeah ha
ha ha now God's gonna be a just once
Oh Dino so thank you for that ha ha ha
ha ha
that was very authentic quack I think
that girl might be a duck
I forgot jeez remember your hello kid
yeah oh yeah I meant I got food and we
frickin audio media and perfect during
the Swedish book signing there was a
couple who had a tiny little bro they
said the youngest bro or whatever so
that's cool they pitted by I'm Lizzy and
is really one to me I love you and
you're amazing and Beryl our manager
anyways I love you and Bubba can do it
that's sweet thank you
it's his dad's catching on ha ha ha Oh
goodbye I'm from Greece and I wanted to
show you the father
hey that's awesome game third opponent
another prevalent hey the grass rope
burn where is the pity pot please
ha here you are fearless back my Soaker
you've heard of her
sound like you really punch you're not
supposed to punch your camera Jesus
Christ does I don't have a lot of time
and you probably won't see this but if
you do all everything is just thank you
thank you for being there and don't stop
okay oh so many of you are saying thank
you for to me but I feel like I I should
say thanks to you for watching so stop
saying things I'm saying things here
okay god dammit
oh my god happy oh you really don't look
happy
jeez is that the new grumpy cat Jesus
Christ thank you thank you for making me
laugh as well I brought it from a loyal
fan from
brofist it's cool to see bros from all
over the world [ __ ] my day PewDiePie
10 out of 10 best song I made me cry
tears hey cutie pie I am a left and I'm
from from would stupid on the screen
come on
I have no idea what he said have the
going bros my name and welcome to dude
yeah
hello p5 my name is me who aspire to be
a youtube i were really happy to hear
this with you video i love it ok hey i
got an actual question uh no one
inspired me in particular I just
remember I love the idea of just sharing
video game moments online I thought that
was a really fun thing and I that's what
I wanted to do what
okay I'm scared ah [ __ ] every time I'm
such a [ __ ] [ __ ] Oh cutie pie why
must I I leave this that's a second
that's a second
well you did at 11 you cheated what it I
will never know why is this camera
underneath the table what kind of what
kind of videos are you making hi Felix
thanks for being a friend for me now
somewhere 40 million people around the
globe all day thank you that means a lot
so please never stop yourself
brofist from the zoo thank you
sounds sweet you guys are so sweet what
the [ __ ]
okay well that was a lot of fun thank
you for us for sending in your messages
if you want to participate in the next
one is with paper I'm going to make
another Facebook post I'll link it in
the description and I'm going to ask you
bros to send me a picture it could be or
whatever that relates to PewDiePie I'll
review it for the next video and that's
it for now if you enjoyed this please
leave it like I really appreciate it and
thank you all for being bros you bros
are the best okay that's all for now as
always stay awesome rose
Wow